5 years ago, we first covered Nvidia's
CMP 170HX, a mining GPU so utterly
worthless that its very existence
offended me. See, unlike a real GPU,
these crypto cards didn't have any
graphics hardware built into them
whatsoever. All they could do was crunch
crypto numbers, meaning that as soon as
they were unprofitable,
they were garbage.
But why? Compute GPUs can be used for
lots of things. And in fact, the A100
cards that these mining cards were
derived from in the first place are
still in high demand for AI
applications. Well, because Nvidia went
out of their way to make them useless.
They crippled the PCI Express bus,
locked the memory down from 64 gigs of
HBM2E to just 8 gigs, meaning it could
barely run any decentsized models. And
to add insult to injury, they locked
down the floating point performance,
too. Which raises the question. I
>> think it lived.
>> Why am I so happy about that? Because as
Lucas from the lab is about to show us,
enterprising modders have found ways to
unlock the floating point performance,
the hidden memory, and even the PCI
Express interface, turning these from
e-waste to E
race racing like they're fast for Whoop,
sorry, I stepped on you. you.
>> I can't
>> fit all of you in my field of view,
[snorts] but we're gonna show you guys
how to do it and talk about whether one
of these cards could be right for you
after the segue to our sh Behold wisdom
from the unmoistened one.
Thank you.
Step one
is to stand on this box so that our
camera operator can frame for both of
us. Step two is to establish a baseline
of what kind of models we can actually
run on this card in its stock
configuration and what it is performance
looks like.
>> We will just be using Llama Bench uh
since it's the simplest.
>> It's not a comprehensive benchmark, but
it gives us a number which is all we
really need to do a comparison like for
like. Literally the exact same card
running the exact same architecture, but
more stronger. You might have noticed
we've got a lot of GPUs on this bench.
The 3090 Ti are here for sort of a
they're not quite equivalent in price,
are they? These are a little more.
>> They were equivalent in price um before
and now they've now the CMPs have shot
up in price. Uh so when we were looking
before they were about 1,100 each uh
11-,300 and now the CMPs are going for
like 16-,900. 3090 Ti are here as sort
of a faster compute but less RAM point
of comparison. We've got a 1650 that's
just here for video output. And then we
have two of these mining cards to show
you how well things can go and also how
not as well things can go with the
unlock.
>> We have long CVP run here on uh with the
granite uh 4.1 model 8 billion. Um so we
can ask it some questions like
>> sure question of the day.
>> Who's the best tech YouTuber? Wow, that
is out of date and also really stupid.
Smosh, lots of love to Ian and Anthony,
but like tech YouTuber. Oh,
>> yeah, we had to choose that basically
cuz that's all we can fit on the 8 GB.
But if we al put that onto the 3090
first, uh we can see it loads much
faster and then we can ask
>> Oh, that did load much faster
>> and it uh it rips away,
>> right? And that just comes down to the
way faster compute because both of them
are running really small models. Now,
what would happen if we tried to run a
larger model on our 8 GB mining card?
>> We use Quen 3.8. You know, it's all the
rage now. I think this is like 28 GBish.
>> To be clear, we do have over 28 gigs of
system memory for it to uh fall back on.
>> It's probably going to fail very soon
here. [laughter] I also like the context
we did for the small model. It could
only be 16k instead of what I would
usually run like 64 on it. I was going
to um but here we can see it.
>> Yeah. So red text is good, right?
>> Yeah, it's the warning one. And then
this should uh this will fit. Actually,
this may might not fit on the 3090, but
it'll fit on two, which we can do as
well.
>> Yeah. Do we have an Envy link bridge? Do
we even need it?
>> Uh we do, but we don't really need it.
We actually didn't see too much of a
gain of it on uh with Envy Link bridge.
That is another thing. the 3090s
sometimes inconsistent and they'll
crash.
>> BRB.
>> With our baseline out of the way, it's
time to perform the unlock. How would
you rate this on a scale of 1 to 10 for
difficulty?
>> Pretty easy. Um,
six. [laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Six. You got to know the little things.
Uh I I think the the relock afterwards
is where I kind of uh it got more
difficult when I was doing that before
this, but uh yeah, it's not too bad. And
there's like steps on in the repo from
this guy, Amog Mooney Cot. I'm going to
butcher his name, but we'll have it
linked of course somewhere.
>> And we'll actually have a link down
below to the full LT Labs companion
article that'll go with this video. So
you're going to want to be sure to check
that out.
>> Yeah, but we just have, you know, the
cloned GitHub repo. Um you have to
disable secure boot. Um, and then nuke
all the existing Nvidia drivers. Um,
just purge those.
>> Blacklist the Neuvo drivers. Uh, so
those don't kind of try to jump in.
>> Yeah. Oh, dude. I ran into that a little
while ago with Fedora. It just like kept
installing drivers that I didn't want
over and over and over again when I was
trying to get some Volta cards working
on. It was a whole thing.
>> Yeah. But there's a kind of config file
you can write to them and so it'll stop
that.
>> Um, rebuild the RAM file system and all
that. um and then specify which drivers
you want because there's specific
drivers that these are built for that
this is built for and this
>> this unlock will act on.
>> Now tell me this another thing I ran up
against is that on Linux or at least on
Fedora it's a little bit more
challenging to run different Nvidia
drivers for your different Nvidia cards
like you can on Windows. Do you have to
run the same Nvidia driver across all
your cards?
>> I actually don't know. I kind of just
stuck with the single driver to to to
make sure it works in this limited time
and with the unlock. So,
>> chat with us in the comments. In the
meantime, though, are we pretty much
ready to press execute and show the
unlocked cards?
>> Uh, yeah.
>> And then basically, instead of unlocking
the card, you're just running like a
modified version of the driver software
that unlocks any card that you put in
the system now. Is that right?
>> Yeah, that's correct. Yeah. There's some
papers in like earlier research on
unlocking the cards specifically and
they're actually really interesting
papers to read, but this one acts on the
system and the drivers. So any card you
plug in will be unlocked and then if you
take that same card, plug it into a
different system, it'll be locked again
until you unlock that system.
>> I love this kind of just like blackmagic
tom foolery.
>> It's very cool uh to see and kind of the
unlocking of uh all this potential and
uh hardware. I mean, some of the papers
I read were like, oh, you know,
investigating this as like, you know,
things we should watch out for, so
people can't unlock them in the future.
But, you know,
>> Oh, those guys.
>> Yeah. Yeah. [laughter]
>> There you go. Sick.
>> Nvidia CMX or CMP 170HX.
>> We didn't even talk about the power
limit going up too then.
>> Uh, yes. Well, actually, it's the same
power limit, but because the compute was
so locked down before, all the
floatingoint operation, it never even
like used anywhere near the 250 W I saw.
But now we could get up near that 250
watts.
>> Definitely. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. Uh
when it's running. Uh depends on what's
running, of course.
>> All right. Well, why don't we start with
that little model and have a look at
what our better floating port
performance gets us.
>> It's actually quite slow, but that
that's mostly because of the PCIe um
lane kind of thing cuz we it unlocks it
to PC Gen 2,
>> but it's still a BY4, so our bandwidth
is seriously limited.
>> Still limited there. Yeah,
>> that can be unlocked, but that takes a
capacitor mod that we'll get into a bit
more later.
>> Is there any fights
and much faster? This is kind of like
what we were seeing with the 3090.
>> Wow, that is worlds faster. Still
completely crap analysis.
>> We'll give it a larger um prompt, too.
>> Sure.
>> Um cuz you don't really see the prompt
processing speed unless you give it a
large prompt like that. And you [music]
can see the 3090 Ti uh single one of
them was getting about 7,000 I think it
was or 4,000 I don't know exact but this
one you know is also up there
>> right? Yeah it it's it's slower right
but this is a completely different world
of speed compared to what it was doing
before. And now let's see what happens
when we load that Quen model that
everyone is mayonnaing themselves over.
>> Okay, here we go.
>> Hopefully it runs. It'll it'll always be
slower to load up. That's kind of the
main uh lock from the PC thing,
>> right? eight because even [music] though
we've got that 64 gigs and it's HPM 2e
which is still very fast like right on
par with the GDDDR7 that you'd get on
something like a 5090
if the data's got to be loaded through
the PCIe bus if that bus is slow then
you got to wait around I mean that
wasn't that bad though
>> yeah it's not too bad it's a it's a
larger model
>> let's ask the same thing and probably
get a way better answer
>> so we'll see if how this runs cuz Quen
likes to think a lot and I didn't give
it any reasoning effort um Okay.
>> Commands. So, it may just think for a
really long time uh before Oh, it says
something there.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> this isn't
it's not ordered.
>> I knew this was going to happen.
>> It's not ordered.
>> I knew it was going to happen.
>> There's no single best. Maybe that is
the smarter uh decision. You know, watch
multiple reviews.
>> This is very usable though. Uh very good
speed. Oh,
>> MKBH.
>> We'll cut that. Cut that. Cut that.
[laughter]
>> All right. Let's see what happens if we
give it a much longer prompt. Now,
>> this will be slower. There'll be some
time to first token. Um, but still quite
quick.
>> That's a thousand words of Laurum.
>> Now, you mentioned before that because
we've got twice the memory of the 3090
Ti, we could actually run even larger
models on our mining card. But question
for you, given that it doesn't have the
fastest compute, would an Aentic
workload make more sense for a card like
this? and would we instead want to just
use that extra VRAM for more context and
then let it churn away at things in the
background.
>> It's really good to have all the extra
memory obviously for the larger um
larger models and also if there's
multiple like concurrency going on so
they all have large contexts um or if
you're doing some kind of task that
needs multiple different models um if
you have like your main one your agent
you're talking to and it's also doing
embedding or image generation. Um, so
that's kind of the advantage you get
from this huge amount of memory.
>> So basically, yes and also yes and also
yes. It's just way more flexibility.
>> I'd love to buy this one off of uh, you
know, logistics.
>> Now, let's try running Quen on our 3090
Ti or should I say 3090 Ti cuz we kind
of have to pull their memory in order to
run that without it crashing or
>> uh, sure. Yeah, we can try running on
just one right now and see how that
>> Okay. I mean,
>> it's going to fail.
>> Crash last time.
>> Uh, yeah, it won't work. Um cuz the
model is like 20 29 GB and then if we
add two of them together.
>> Mhm.
>> Just on layer split mode this will work
since we got 48 GB.
>> Okay.
>> We should get a very similar quality of
answer and we should actually get
measurably more performance in this
case.
>> I think it actually is
>> looks really similar.
>> Slower. Yeah.
>> So prompt got 164 but it's such a small
prompt. Generation out we got 30.
>> Not as much of a difference as you might
think but let's go ahead and throw a
bigger prompt in there. And so that was
a bit of a pause, but that was like I
think 2,000 words or something. Um, and
it'll think for a while to about 2,000
tokens per second,
>> right? Okay. So that's where the better
compute of the 3090 Ti comes into play.
Of course, just like we can run two 3090
Ti, we can also run two mining cards.
This is where once again the PCIe
bandwidth limitations could rear their
ugly heads. Yeah, it does depend
slightly as well on the tensor versus um
layer split mode um like parallelism.
And it's kind of the same thing again
where it's like there's so many factors
that could you know limit it, bottleneck
it or make it speed up.
>> That's his way of saying
>> that these are not certified labs test
results.
>> It depends.
>> These are quick and dirty illustrative
numbers and anyone actually deploying
these would do a bunch more tuning and
almost certainly get better results. as
we've been doing like in the discord
they have got there for the CMP and
locker they've been doing a lot of
different uh really cool things there so
you should check that as well so I'm
kind of expecting you know half the
prompt processing speed of it um but
same token generation
>> still really usable
>> yeah this is great for like if you're
using some local coding or whatever
agentic thing [music] over like 10 to 15
is usually pretty good for kind of
expect but yeah
>> but it's not all sunshine and rainbows
either as Lucas already alluded to in
the time since this unlock lock was
discovered to the time that we're
filming, these have gone up very
significantly in price. And there's no
guarantee whatsoever that you're going
to actually get a working one. In fact,
even though we were able to process a
prompt just now on these two cards, one
of them is bad.
>> Let me show you what that means here.
So, we'll mem test this and we'll try to
target one of the 170HXs. So this test
will just, you know, go through all of
the memory and check it for any errors
that like write and read it back to see
if anything's changed. It should show up
in the within the first five minutes of
the test, even faster on my previous
tests. But this, I would say, seems like
the good one. [laughter]
>> See, there's lots of reasons that a card
might be [clears throat] demoted from
A100 to crap mining card. Maybe it
doesn't meet the power threshold. Maybe
it doesn't meet the quality standards.
Or maybe the HBM memory, which if you
guys recall is right on the package and
once it's installed, cannot be removed,
was damaged or otherwise failed during
manufacturing. And when that happens,
what Nvidia was doing was they were
basically fusing off most of it and
selling it as a crap mining card. So
whether you get one that has a memory
defect or some other kind of defect,
pure luck of the draw. And like [snorts]
Lucas mentioned, maybe not even pure
luck because a lot of people are going
to be buying these in bulk, binning
them, and selling the crap ones to take
advantage of the current market
situation.
>> Oh,
>> so there we go. Memory found a bad one.
[clears throat]
>> So if it's all good, it'll kind of just
keep showing through the list and show
iterations as it goes.
>> Yeah.
>> Standard 5 minute and you should let it
go for longer. But this one, bad
sectors.
>> And what does that mean? That basically
means that at some point we're going to
ask it to do some math and it's going to
burp out.
>> Whatever you're running is going to
crash. I saw some stuff on the Discord
where people were trying to trying to
run it um and they were seeing you know
inconsistency. We didn't see any
inconsistency but we didn't run it for a
long time like that. Who we borrowed
this card from said that as it gets
really hot sometimes that fixes their
kind of inconsistency. Um like when it's
above like 85° kind of like the limit
there. Um but who knows? I wouldn't rely
on that for production. But if you do
get a good card, there's another step
that you can go to to unlock even
further performance. Using some leaked
schematics on the 170th Street repo, our
resident soldering wizard Dan managed to
put the 24 little tiny capacitors back
on this thing above the PCIe slot,
unlocking
full 16 functionality. So, let's go
ahead and throw two modded cards into
our system and see how they fly. Uh,
while we're performing this operation,
seems as good a time as any to talk
about cooling these monsters. This is
the same shroud that we used last time
around. We'll have it linked in the
video description. What's good about
this approach is it works pretty well
and is reasonably quiet. But what sucks
about it is it takes up a lot of space,
forcing the use of risers, which just
adds another variable whenever you run
into flaky behavior. So, if you're more
interested in water cooling, you'll find
more information about that on 170th
Street. I guess you're waiting for me to
give you this so you have the can have
the fan. I'm so sorry. I don't think
we're going to get into the nuance of
how different concurrency methods might
benefit more or less from the additional
bandwidth. I just want to see something
everyone will benefit from, which is
faster model loadins. So, want to throw
Quinn in there. Loading model. And this
was, if you remember, quite slow the
first time around on a single card.
And that was quite not nearly as slow.
So, what's the takeaway?
>> Is that rhetorical for me?
>> Uh, no. No, we're going to answer it in
a second. I mean, sure. Yeah. Take a
crack at it.
>> Uh, buy one, I guess,
>> if you can get a working one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I think it's great. Um,
it kind of fits all of the standard
large kind of models you'd fit cuz
they're kind of now contained between
like the 20 to 40 GB range and leaves a
lot of room for context to make it Yeah.
like half a million or quarter a million
context
>> or running additional models.
>> Uh, it's fast enough to interact with in
real time, but definitely fast enough to
work on agentic tasks in the background.
There are some inconveniences, but even
at the current pricing, um, I think it's
pretty good deal. And there will be more
optimizations and people finding
workarounds for things, maybe some more
unlocks as well. So, pretty interesting.
>> Future's bright because it contains this
segue to our sponsor.
>> Busy
[music]
>> water. No
water.
No.
>> No, I haven't seen him. I know it's cats
and dogs out there. I hope he's wearing
his messy [music] classic Chelseies.
>> Dampertton Falls had never been this
damp. Like an infection. [music]
The rain wormed its way into every
crevice. There wasn't a dry sock in the
city except the one inside that
thing.
Expect the unexpected with the Vessie
Weekend Chelsea. Lightweight,
breathable, comfortable, and waterproof.
Bet you didn't see that coming. Simple,
[music] stylish, and versatile. It's one
pair for whatever might happen.
[music] It's existence is a paradox.
Does that mean it [music] can't be real?
Or that you can't get 15% off your first
order [music] with a one-year warranty
and free shipping on North American
orders? [music]
over $110.
Just embrace
Vessie.
Now, to return most of these to their
rightful owner. If you guys enjoyed this
video, maybe check out the one where we
used a different cut down mining card
for gaming by routing its GPU power
through our onboard graphics,
which if that sounds complicated, it's
because it was a little bit.